[Musique]
il ya 40 ans serge fiori et richard
séguin ont créé un album qui est passé à
l'histoire
je suis un père de serge charron fêter
40 et a milité pour laisser passer ça
c'est quand même assez étonnant de voir
ça comme ça
[Musique]
200 nuits à l'heure et l'album de deux
grands artistes à la croisée des chemins
1977 richard séguin voulait tourner la
page sur son compte les séguin serge
fiori pensait déjà à l'après harmonium
mois à travers la fin des tournées dans
mon nom je commence à vraiment c'est
chez les choses à son niveau n'a amené
que jamais un vrai que le tournus
fonctionnement
j'ai commencé la jav a pu jeter ou si
nous n'avons pu puis l'ont nos véhicules
vraiment une fraternité
[Musique]
en quelques mois ces deux grands amis
ont fait enregistrer sa chanson devenus
des classiques bon départ l'album devait
être le résultat probant on doit faire
l'album avec michel rivard qui reçoit un
appel de michel qui était en belgique et
d'y continuer sans - juste avant l'amour
je ressemble j'ai fait que subsiste car
même à ces fumées c'est ce qui arrive
[Applaudissements]
serge fiori et michard seguin ont
remporté trois prix félix avec 200 nuits
à leurs quarante ans plus tard lloris et
guettent des poussières cet album pour
le rééditer leur master et un sac à vomi
ce faire ça donne une ronde à l'album
come on savait la vente en même temps
c'est le 40e
et l'avenir pourrait nous réserver
surprise richard séguin nous apprend que
dans son sous sol il y aurait des
enregistrements inédits de fiori séguin
s'était papier
[Musique]
quoi
que tu vas
ici louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
m'ont rien